Ken have you ever made an apology video
no and I hope I never have to good me
neither cuz today we're reviewing
apology videos oh we're what do you
think we're yes we're going to rate them
and I've added a little bonus game
Bingo YouTube apology Bingo here you get
a card I get a card I love Bingo I've
never actually played this is my first
time playing bingo you've never played
Bingo before Oh man so let's see what we
have here avoid eye contact with camera
mhm looks like you got to look bad
yeah crying PL and line deleted video
we'll go through these as we go on it's
been so long I used to rate all the
apology videos I'm kind of kind of an
expert I actually realized there's so
many apology videos now like you can
take any YouTuber and then just add
apology and see if it comes up like it's
a game on its own right a lot of stuff
has gone wrong lately it's getting bad
out there first apology video you know
what it is I
can't damn it I think that's our first
Bingo Ken quite possibly the worst
apology video of
all
check she whipped out the ukulele for
this one huh I can't watch this video
it's too cringy I can never make it past
like the one minute Mark she literally
did just whoop out the ukulele still got
the dust under the strings and
everything oh you're right well spotted
the Hawkeye can again yeah I'm on it
don't you worry okay let's watch the
apology and we'll raid it and see if we
had any more bingos keep an eye out on
your bingo card Ken oh there there's a
lot coming on this one already I'm just
[Music]
looking is that dramatic dramatic pause
I think I had that in there dramatic
started out with avoiding eye contact
with camera but we got dramatic pause
dramtic
[Music]
PA hey it's been a while since you saw
my face I haven't been doing so great so
I took a little break God I didn't think
there would be this many bingos uh my
feelings I think I had like like my
feelings I'm not doing great I'm doing
terrible you guys having
fun this is the funniest video of all
[Music]
time do you think the new uh apology
meta is just going to be releasing songs
now is there spot is there Spotify no it
came came I think after this one
everyone knows not to do
this I don't know how they I I feel like
people should have realized by now like
how to apologize right it shouldn't be
that hard say you're sorry just say
you're sorry own up to what you did but
they just can't do it people just can't
do it I want a Spotify link of
this uh hi everyone I've been wanting to
come online and talk to you about a few
things um even though my team has
strongly advised me to not say what I
want to say I recently realized that
they never said that I couldn't sing
what I want to say oh God
God damn listen Felix my team all they
want is the best for me and my success
they told me not to make this but you
know what didn't say I couldn't sing it
so here we go it's just how she expects
it to be like oh wow that's so clever I
what do you think we're going to react
like wow I can't she has a good point
actually yes I can't believe
it oh God if the people looking after
you are saying don't do something
absolutely don't do this you probably
should listen no know she she a big deal
whatever you know it's just a bunch of
people being toxic it's a gossip train
people just doing it for you know
they're reacting to for the views you
know it's not even a big deal I feel
sick I hate watching this video I'm
still impressed how this thing has had
13,000 comments for like the last two
months that's a lot of comments though
two hours ago two hours ago two hours
ago 16 one oh there's a big gap in uh oh
my fing God she still does it this is
like 5 months old
oh my
God God days oh my God 2 hours ago stay
strong she was here she was sitting here
2 hours ago for a five months old video
only positivity in this comment section
okay no hate this hurts me man I cannot
this is beyond this is I didn't this
long fire she sit there and she goes yes
that one I will approve that
one
Let's test that Spotify link when newest
comment it's not there no it's not there
it's not there I don't see it the last
one I see is the St strong there it's
not
there oh they're all held for review
that's what it is and they they're
actually approving that's what I mean
that's what I mean she's approving them
I feel like that counts as deleting
comments or something I think disabling
comments there you go that's another one
um today I only want to talk about the
facts
so I hope that you'll be willing to
listen no this is painful I can't do it
many years ago I used to message my fans
uh but so she has this really child like
I can't imagine anyone but an infant
child watching her videos cuz she does
this character but she was just texting
fans kind of treating them like therapy
super inappropriate conversations like
sexual topics asking if they were a
virgin sending her underwear to her fans
that's what I like I haven't even looked
into it to be honest I'm sure there's
more but like that's what I got out of
it it's a kind of thing where at some
point she should have realized you know
what this is [__]
weird that's a character though a
characters to be weird just like at some
point she should have realized you know
what maybe I shouldn't whip out ukul
Alan sing but I I guess some people just
don't have that listen I definitely
don't have the best sensor either but
Jesus Christ I don't have this level of
narcissism I
don't nism isn't it it is Holy cuz she
expects everyone to be like wow that's
so cute she has her little ukele I love
it a creepy way like a lot of you are
trying to suggest it was more of a loser
kind of way where I was just trying to
be besties with everybody it's still
creepy though yeah yeah like just cuz
your intention is different doesn't mean
it's not creepy to send your you're
underwear to someone I mean and she goes
through it like for all the people
who've already watched it like lightly
touches on some of the allegations but
there's like a channel that like has all
the messages you can go like read them
all yourself and like make your come to
your own conclusions right and they're
pretty wild I guess that's why I'm
taking this so lightly cuz I don't even
know half the story well I mean like you
can't take it seriously she's playing
ukulele right now video how are you
supposed to like when you paused it oh
yeah that's not her angle let's just say
that
details of my life which was really
weird of me I haven't done that for
years you see cuz I changed my behavior
and I took accountability is that a
bingo she took accountability when now
in the ukulele
[Laughter]
[Music]
video but that's not very interesting is
it so let's go on the toxic gossip
train so [__] n rat I would never
make a mistake like that oh I'm sorry I
didn't realize that all of you are
perfect so please criticize me bring out
the daggers made from your perfect past
and stab me repeatedly in my bony little
back godamn godamn Jesus said he without
sin cast the first stone you can't judge
me you've guys have done bad stuff too
there you of course of course we can
that's how it works everyone can I can
be the worst person in the planet and
still be like you're a piece of [__]
absolutely you know what would have been
a better apology what if she just came
out of nowhere and hit us with this one
take this chance to
apologize to absolutely
nobody [__] that would have been a
better
apology my freaking
headphon I'm sorry to nobody absolutely
nobody it's basically what most apology
videos are these days anyway yeah you're
right you're right it's just a
convoluted way of saying it yeah you
like you give you give the people enough
they like oh okay well she said she's
sorry and then you still have enough to
where people talk about it and you get
the free publicity from it but you're
really not sorry and you just move on
with your life and you keep doing what
you do I would actually like to take
this time to apologize myself for
nothing today's sponsor Clash of Clans
you didn't guess it I'm playing Clash of
Clans they invited me for their charity
event Clash of nature I'm competing I
need help help me supercell the creator
of the game have deviced or master plan
to save the planet through echo-friendly
housing which I've built here it's
really nice solar and everything no by
pillaging my Viking ancestors I know
they're behind me they're going yes
they're going what's that that's a game
based on realtime strategy elements yes
yes it is with Base building and
Resource Management yes all right I'm
[Music]
pillaging snep F7 733 if you're watching
I hope you're
humiliated as you can see I'm getting
golden resources this will all count
towards our charity goal we're trying to
raise 100,000 it will go for team trees
or team C's I'm team trees so join my
team there it is beautiful so pillers
away for a good C but here's the best
bit if our team wins 50 of you will win
a kit with supercell merch it gets
better okay it gets better you know what
I will win if we win a
Tesla you get special merch I get a
Tesla use SEC C code download now play
it while the video goes on I don't care
I want a Tesla I need two Teslas I want
to ride one with both legs like this
thank you class of clients for
sponsoring this video let's keep going
um I didn't realize it was my
responsibility to decide what was
appropriate for every kid to see is that
shifting blame yeah oh yeah yeah
defitely definitely a shifting BL there
we go hope you had some
fun 8 minutes thank God it's over Ken
actually you know
[__] God damn
it not he's not done ran about it yet
she rehearsed that she was like you know
it would be cool if I like no I got more
[__] to say this is all impr promp from
here maybe you're confused about
something I don't know
[Music]
let me try to help um that's it I'm not
doing it thank you that's too much man I
can't believe she did that so she
eventually comes back in a later video
this like a 10-minute Vlog but like for
like a minute of it she says she's sorry
in a more sincere way oh yes she didn't
actually apologize I think I had that or
did she apologize there we
go was that an apology I don't think so
all right why should we rate this
apology K I mean it's probably the best
thing I've ever seen I don't think it
gets better than this actually 10 out of
10 Peak apology Peak I agree with that
10 out of 10 10 bananas out of 10 all
right I have so many apologies Ken I
have two parts of this I feel like this
is ridiculous I realiz it take so long
Logan Paul yay Logan Paul he's back he's
back baby I felt bad for him for a while
cuz it seemed like he was genuinely like
oh no I I made a mistake you know I'm
like okay we'll give him another chance
and then he just started like like with
all the crypto sh oh maybe not maybe
some people never change people never
change he had this crypto thing where it
was like a coin they were trying to make
it like a Dogecoin and they call it dink
coin or something dink dink and it's so
cringy have did you see any of this I
haven't actually seen this yet I know
about the crypto Zoo stuff but not about
yeah they did this one first where
they're like oh do Dogecoin is getting
big so we're going to do our own but
we're going to pretend like yeah it's
just like the funniest thing ever it's
me Logan Paul now I know what you're
thinking Logan what the f are you doing
here I'm doing the same thing as you
holding my dink that's what I'm doing
this is a [__] coin I believe in he
believes in it I wonder why I wonder why
probably not cuz he has like already a
bunch of money in it they try to make it
like South Park it's just embarrassing
and lo and behold he helped to create it
can you believe it K what what
surprise guys you should put all your
money in this thing that I found it's so
funny oh my God whenever I think of
trust PE YouTubers that I trust content
creators that I trust Logan Paul
definitely always at the top anything he
does absolutely I trust it and of course
as you know nfts now worthless who would
have thought what oh no way so he did
the crypto Zoo where you hatch eggs to
make it more exciting and you get funny
little
pictures that's one of the things you
can mate the eggs with each other and
some bad AI animal mix pretty much yeah
it's a panda and an elephant and it's
hilarious so he got called out basically
like abandoning this project and leaving
everyone that put money into it just to
like rot I guess this is his response
and surely you knew amilio the gentleman
who supposedly let his child invest in a
cryptocurrency was allegedly responsible
for two so this is Shi in blame but we
already we already have that so either
did we already have that yeah yeah all
right good another one did he delete
this video cuz see it's re-uploaded oh
deleted
video
yay thank you thank you you missed that
or you knew it and failed to let the
public know why because it was a clear
sign that he was also untrustworthy you
seem you he like you idiot calling me
out you missed that he's an criminal how
how dare you miss that my employees that
I hired po criminals you idiot you think
you did research look at all this sh I
can't believe he uploaded this well I
guess you realized and deleted it after
12 months of work you still managed to
overlook one crucial piece of
information see even though I've said
it's coming so many times you've assumed
that crypto Zoo isn't being made who are
you to decide when the development
timeline ends do you think it's released
yet Ken this coming soon how how dare I
assume when the development period is
over it's right around the corner it's
coming eventually I think he's in some
legal trouble because of this I don't
know how severe it is but I think that's
probably the reason why I guess we
should watch the apology or response to
this like he just goes on his podcast
and he talks about it what do I do what
do I do I actually have an answer for
that when you're on the top rope at WWE
and you're going like this after a crazy
show and the audience is going crazy
when you're bringing Prime into the what
I'm just is this the apology or is it
just like a shout out to all his
products you know what he's got going on
promoting merch there we go yeah got it
all right we're don't have time zero I
give this zero out of 10 Logan Paul
tired of this are you ready for the best
apology video I have ever seen in my
entire life I can't believe this almost
flew under my radar do you know the Tik
tocker
Sienna me M almost 13 million
followers 1.1 billion likes God dang
[__] I'm not keeping up with this
what she did was pretty uh what's the
word ag agous ag what the was
that look those perfect ass waves I hate
her even more
now how the where did she she flat out
on camera uh sexually assaulted gred a
guy that was completely unconscious all
over him it's pretty horrible to see it
she got C like there there's no doubt
like you see the clip you're like what
the her apology video have you seen it
no I know she diding god dude no I'm
already looking at that no is it like
yeah yeah yeah it's the millennial
apology can like a mood board yeah I
don't F I can't believe this neity
surrounding my platform it was honestly
one of the most difficult times in my
life for many reason but through
struggle I found Clarity Within Myself
and with who I want to surround myself
with my purpose in this life is all
right hold on hold on hold on hang on
clearly reading a script we got that on
the bingo card right
yay there we go silly Tik Tok dances or
showing unedited photos of myself
creating sexually assaulting other
people and inspiring is what fulfills me
I know that this is why God and the
universe have given me this platform
Jesus Christ shut the
God
damn self love but that takes time she's
chosen man she's the chosen one that's
main character to the next level man
Jesus Christ I think a lot of people my
age can relate to I hope this can
inspire you she wants to inspire us she
sit in a lingerie too yeah this is like
oh this is like that when you got to
like like down to earth and as normal as
you can when you're making your apology
yeah yeah she's vulnerable right now I
understand really she wants to inspire
us you know she get you get called out
for something that's illegal uh horrible
uh but she wants to inspire us so thank
you for that appreciate that are you
ready to be inspired Ken I I'm already
inspired I'm feeling
[Music]
great I can't watch this [__] what what
about
watching is she is she apologizing
through interpretive dance right now
yes she
[Laughter]
is it's so bad too oh God I can't
believe I've never seen this before holy
sh i f to and I was like holy [__] this
is like you couldn't make this up I
thought that ukulele was bad
yes this is the new meta this
interpreted dance
apology man she's hitting those moves
like I do in Tekken when I'm playing
Eddie you know just butt
Mash you know the
ones I feel inspired to kill
myself oh the lyrics are I've done
nothing wrong the oh my
God we have to put a different track but
that's the lyrics I'm we hearing oh
God oh my God I can't believe it it's
just you know a lot of thought and time
goes into these things right she didn't
just like have this ready there's
multiple camera angles too so they like
did this several times whole production
crew and yeah unbelievable I don't know
if she titled it apology I think she did
it's qu was it a reupload where did this
come from was it deleted yeah this is
another deleted video you already have
that yeah we already got that yeah we
just need two long explanation sigh and
dark place or how is this how is this
relevant
oh I guess when they I think we probably
hit that one quite a few times
already all right see if we can get
another one we got more Ken I'm going to
speed up a little bit cuz we taking some
time I found a Pokemon has a apology
video does she what does she apologize
for I discovered this fun little thing
that you can do is you play the video I
hope you're doing well and then you just
read the comments instead trying to
figure out what she's
in I know this video over one year later
I still don't know what she's
apologizing for according to Japanese
scientist if you're not sleeping it's
probably because you're
awake wow this is kind of the situation
I think most content creators hope for
when they do something wrong is they
just keep going and eventually no one
knows what you did wrong
anyway wow this is crazy do you know the
first person convicted of speed was
going 8 Miles hour damn that's crazy
again oh God it goes on for so long
there we go long
explanation I also saw KSI had one and
he yeah it was he used a racial slur uh
I think at least I don't know we don't
have to get into it I just find it
hilarious the setting for some
reason we always got start out with like
you know it not looking like a well
edited video or anything right you know
got to where is he behind the scenes
here he's on a roof it looks like in the
background he's like morning morning
everyone but there's it seems like no
one is there like it's so
quiet so you know I want to read a St
quiet on the set you know which I've
written to make
sure just looks like he's
St why they set him in front of like the
backdrop if they're not even going to
like but yeah no it's good he took a
it's a good apology I think he did a
good job I just thought the whole
setting was funny but maybe it wasn't
just to me Lage Tech TI
did you know this oh my god did he yeah
I'll kept up with this a little bit he
didn't apologize until everyone until
got really
bad I don't I don't understand what
happened I think it was I watched his
videos and he's always like repping on
like the big companies they're so stupid
they do all these mistakes and then it's
like he has done every big company bad
mistake there is basically and now it is
a big company because it's worth like so
much exactly yeah full circle it starts
off with the years ago when he said why
the [__] are you here I've never seen an
apology with this many people involved
and then finally lus St where the
Channel shows up a number of times there
he
is sad L is thinking retiring three
years
ago it was a golden opportunity to show
up like this why did he come in like
this come
on oh imagine that would been so good
that would have been perfect what's up
guys I think that was uh all my apology
videos Ken that was it wow really we hit
the Bing gum we did it huge we've missed
out at some of these I don't know man
I'm inspired you know oh inspired that's
good yeah she did that there was
definitely a couple signs and we got
free for free yeah free free I would I
contact I feel like we definitely got
from colen a so close damn we almost got
the whole jackpot can Jesus Christ keep
going we'll fill the whole board up I
promise well that was a lot of fun
obviously you know people make mistakes
I don't know what that feels like or how
you do but it happens I guess to some
people Ken do you think I should win a
Tesla absolutely check out the link in
description so I can win
Tesla wow yeah check out Ken that's it